reason is a slave of the passions that
was david hume's view yeah i mean
yeah do you want to know my problem with
fumes i had a radical conversion this is
this might not be connected it's not
connected to psycinfo but i don't i had
a radical conversion i used to have a
more humane view
uh when i was a graduate student
but i was persuaded
by uh some professors at the university
of reading where i was
that if you have the humane view you
have to say
any basic
life goals are
equal
equally valid
so for example let's take someone whose
basic goal in life
is counting blades of grass right
and crucially they don't enjoy it right
this is the crucial point they get no
pleasure from it that's just their basic
goal to spend their life counting as
many blades of grass as possible not for
some greater gold that's just their
basic goal
i i want to say that that is objectively
stupid that is objectively pointless i
shouldn't say stupid movie it's
objectively pointless
uh in a way
that pursuing pleasure or pursuing
someone else's pleasure or pursuing
scientific inquiry is not pointless as
soon as you make that admission you're
not a follower of david hume anymore you
think there are
objective facts about what goals are
worth pursuing
is it possible to have a goal without
pleasure so this kind of uh
idea that you disjoint the two
so the
david foster wallace idea of you know
the key to life is to be unborable isn't
it possible to discover the pleasure in
everything in life the counting of the
the blades of grass
once you see the mastery the skill of it
you can discover the pleasure therefore
you know
um i guess what i'm asking is
why and when and how did you lose the
romance in grad school
[Laughter]
is that what you're trying to say
i think
it may or may not be true that it's
possible to find pleasure in everything
but i think it's also true that
people don't act solely for pleasure and
they certainly don't actually for their
own pleasure people will
suffer for things they think are
worthwhile i might you know i might
suffer for some scientific cause for
um
finding out a cure for the pandemic or
and
in terms of my own pleasure i might
have less pleasure in doing that but i
think it's worthwhile it's a worthwhile
thing to do i don't i just don't think
it's the case that
everything we do is is rooted in
maximizing our own pleasure i don't
think that's even psychologically
plausible but pleasure then that's a
narrow kind of view of play that's like
a short-term pleasure but you can see
pleasure is a kind of uh
ability to hear the music in the
distance it's like yes it's difficult
now it's suffering now
but there is some greater thing beyond
the mountain
that would be joy i mean that's kind of
uh even if it's not in this life
well you know the warriors will meet in
valhalla
right the feeling that gives meaning and
fulfillment to life is not necessarily
grounded in pleasure
of like the counting of the grass it's
something else i don't know um the
struggle is a source of
deep fulfillment so like i think
pleasure needs to be kind of
thought of as
a little bit more broadly it's just kind
of
gives you this sense
it uh for a moment allows you to forget
the terror of the fact that you're going
to die
that that that's pleasure like that's
the broader view of pleasure that you
get to kind of uh
play
in the little illusion that all of this
has deep meaning
that's pleasure yeah well
but i mean you know people
sacrifice their lives uh atheists may
sacrifice their lives for the sake of
someone else or for the sake of
something important enough and
clearly in that case they're not um
doing it for the sake of their own
pleasure that's a rather dramatic
example but they can be just trivial
examples where
um
you know i i choose to
be honest rather than um
lie about something can i lose out a bit
and i um i have a bit less pleasure but
i thought it was worth doing the honest
thing or something i mean i just think
so that's a
i mean maybe you can use the word
pleasure so broadly that you're just
essentially meaning something worthwhile
but then
i think the word pleasure maybe maybe
loses its meaning
uh sure wow
but what do you think about the blades
of grass case what do you think about
someone who spends their life counting
blades of grass and doesn't enjoy it
so i think i personally think it's
impossible or maybe i'm not
understanding
even like the philosophical formulation
but i think it's impossible to have a
goal and not draw pleasure from it
make it worthwhile forget the word
pleasure
i think
the word goal loses meaning if i say i'm
going to count the number of pens on
this table
if i'm actively involved in the task i
will find
joy in it i will find out like i think
there's a lot of meaning and joy
to be discovered in the uh
in the skill of a task in mastering of a
skill
and and and taking pride in and doing it
well i mean that's
i don't know what it is about the human
mind but there's there's some uh
joy to be discovered in the mastery of a
skill
so i think it's just impossible to count
blades of grass and not sort of have the
giro dreams of sushi
uh compelling like draws you into the
mastery of the simple task
um
yeah i suppose i mean
in a way you might think it's it's it's
just hard to imagine someone who would
spend their lives doing that but then
maybe that's just because it's so
evident
that that is a pointless task whereas
if we take this david humebu seriously
it ought to be you know a totally
possible life goal whereas i mean i
yeah i guess i just find it hard to
shake the idea that
some ways of
um some life goals are more worthwhile
than others and it doesn't mean you know
that there's a one single way you should
lead your life but
pursuing knowledge helping people um
pursuing your own pleasure to an extent
are a worthwhile things to do in the in
a way that you know for example i have
i'm a little bit ocd i i still feel
inclined to
walk on cracks in the pavement or do it
symmetrically like if i
step on a crack with my left foot i feel
the need to do it my right foot and
um
i think that's kind of pointless it's
something i feel the urge to do but it's
pointless whereas
other things i choose to do i think
there's
it's worth doing and
um it's hard to make sense of
metaphysically what could possibly
ground that how could we know about
these facts but
that's the starting point for me i don't
know i think you walking
on the sidewalk in a way that's
symmetrical
brings uh order to the world like if you
weren't doing that the world might fall
apart and you it feels like that
i think there's there's um there's
meaning in that like you
embracing the full
like the full experience of that you
living the richness to that as if it has
meaning will give meaning to it and then
whatever genius comes of that as you as
a one little intelligent aunt will make
a better life for everybody else perhaps
i'm defending the the blades of grass
example because i can literally imagine
myself enjoying this task as somebody
who's right ocd in a certain kind of way
in quantitative but now you're ruining
these um because you imagine someone
enjoying it i'm imagining someone who
doesn't enjoy it we don't want a life
that's
just full of pleasure like we just sit
there you know
having a big sugar high all the time we
want a life where we do things that are
worthwhile
if for something to be worthwhile just
is for it to be a basic life goal
then
um
that
that mode of reflection doesn't really
make sense we can't really think did i
do things worthwhile on the on the david
hume type picture
all it is for something to be worthwhile
is it was a basic goal of yours or
derived from a basic goal and
yeah yeah i mean i i think goal and
worthwhile aren't
i think goal is a boring word i'm more
sort of existential is like
did you ride the roller coaster of life
did you fully experience life
that
and and in that sense i mean the blaze
of grass
is something that could be deeply joyful
and that's
in that way i think suffering can be
joyful in the full context of life it's
the roller coaster of life like without
suffering without struggle without pain
without depression or sadness there's
not the highs i mean that's just yeah
that's the up thing about life is
that um
the lows
really make the highs
that much
richer and deeper and
and like tastes better right like the
like i was i tweeted this i was i
couldn't sleep and i was like late at
night
and i know it's like uh obvious
statement
but
like every love story
eventually
you know ends in loss
in tragedy
so like this feeling of love
at the end there's always going to be
tragedy even if it's the most amazing
lifelong love with another human being
one of you is going to die
and i don't know which is worse
but both both are not going to be pretty
and so
that
the sense that it's finite the sense
that it's going to end in a low
that gives like richness
to those kind of evenings when you
realize this thing ends this
thing ends
the the feeling that it ends
the the that that
that bad taste that bad feeling that it
ends gives meaning gives joy gives i
don't know pleasure this loaded word but
gives some kind of uh deep pleasure to
the experience when it's good
and i i mean and that's the blades of
grass
you know they they have that to me um
but you're perhaps right that it's uh
like uh reducing it to a set of goals or
something like that
is is um kind of removing the magic of
life because i think what makes counting
the blaze of grass joyful is
it's just because it's life
you